so Elon Musk and I keep having this
argument I say I say the self-driving
cars are AI he says that they aren't
okay what do you know Elon and you
really wants to believe you're chillin
with Elon listen
Elon and I go back a long way don't you
go back just because he doesn't know
that
what is AI how can you define if you
were to put machine learning and AI into
these two Venn diagrams I think machine
learning would fall inside the AI bubble
but it wouldn't fill it so I guess
that's a nice way of saying AI is very
broad and machine learning is this
applicable more directional application
of AI right so where were you teach
teaching a computer to be really good at
chess or a teaching a computer to be
really good at navigating on a road in a
3,000 pound steel box self-driving right
things like that are applications of
machine learning they can learn the
situation they're in over and over and
over and get better at it which is
something you can do with AI as well as
many other things so now what happens
when the machine is able to teach itself
because that is what human beings do
that would still be machine learning in
fact that's essentially what it does
after a while you feed it an algorithm
enough data over and over again that is
able to teach itself based on its
previous self that'll happen with a
chess robot playing against a chess
robot that's how it gets better plus it
can play an entire game of chess very
fast right oh yeah with computer power
race a little more instant day one yeah
put on there three one more abstract
less direct topics like having a
conversation I don't know if you've ever
tried Siri or Google assistant or bixby
for that matter not that good they learn
everyday they get better at things like
hey what's the weather in Akron Ohio and
it'll tell you and you'll say what's the
population there it knows you're talking
about Akron without you saying it again
and it answers that question kind of
like a human would because of the
proximity and time we're having to
manage and eccrine yes so it identifies
what was the noun in the previous
question and clicks it the next one so
things like that are are getting better
but still it's not as direct as truck
has a problem single remembers the nouns
that I have in the sentence live a
sentence is actually happening I am
having difficulty you need more RAM or
AI which is a sort of a bigger more
broad fear would be like what if it goes
beyond doing what it's programmed to
you what if it learns about itself its
own existence I've heard you mention
earlier I'll just unplug it if it ever
gets out of hand but what if it decides
it you know what I don't want to be
unplugged and it starts to figure out
ways and it's a weird physical analogy
but it starts to figure things out that
it's not directly programmed to do and
whether or not those things get out of
hand or get scary or get weird is a
totally open-ended question you just you
just described sky meant
that's just what you just described is
Skynet it's a network of computers that
become self-aware because of one central
computer and then decides oh you know
what I think I want to run this whole
thing I need to protect myself from risk
and separate myself from that human
variable right and just go rogue I don't
think we're gonna build the robot that
can do everything because what good is
that we have very specific needs that
will create computers to do that we've
been doing it and we'll continue to do
so I don't need the clock the machine
that makes my coffee to be the one that
drives my car I don't need that that
will be kind of cool though yeah it
would be a really weird machine would be
a weird people to think that up and to
make that happen and people keep
thinking robots as being humanoid and
they walk and talk like in the Jetsons
the maid Rosie
yeah that's creepy I'm not even gonna
I'm not even gonna ask beyond that okay
that's just creepy and she had a apron a
maid's apron and so there was a day out
of which I grew up where no one imagined
a machine as a robot a robot had to be
humanoid so this self-driving car would
be a robot that got in a car and drove
you somewhere not that the car was the
robot right that an automatic coffee
maker was a robotic maid that made your
coffee for you not the coffee maker that
made so so I see distributed AI making
our lives easier but let me ask you
something because there's a whole other
side of this equation if it replaces 80
percent of the jobs in society then how
does anyone pay rent and for the
groceries or is there or is there gonna
be sort of a government
minimum income enabled by all the money
earned by the robots that took your job
people's jobs will become making those
robots optimizing those robots there
will be a lot more scientists a lot more
people coding and and figuring out ways
to make those robots better and more
efficient as opposed to those physical
manual things that the robots their own
damn problem with that is we are now we
now have robots that actually code yeah
so we have robots we have robots that's
six robots we have robots that
manufacturer so going back to Neil's
point at some point I think you're gonna
have to have a universal basic income
that you just give people here for being
so that robots so that basically they
can have time to do bigger and better
things with a philosophical question who
fixes the robot that fixes the Roofus I
was gonna say is it robots all the way
down there's a robot
I'm telling you started a little tree
down to one unit robot and the one at
the bottom has got to be human yeah and
his name is Elon Musk just sitting
around what does a to drop wait like
waiting for that robot that can't fix
itself so just might everything we just
said robots could take your job but
machines have trouble when it comes to
crucial open-ended endeavors like
problem-solving and communicating ideas
thank God or more importantly telling
jokes so for now but if you're still
unsure then you can go get comfortable
at brilliant doc org which guides you in
problem-solving understanding concepts
and to get started go to brilliant work
slash start off to get 20% off your
premium subscription so that you can be
an effective problem solver and secure
our future okay if you want to see more
videos from start off hit the subscribe
par and click the little Bell button to
get notifications every single time that
we upload a video and give us a like or
a comment to express your passion
and we want to say thanks to mph D for
being with us and we're gonna be your
channel as well exactly right cool so
make sure you check him out and as
always I bid you to keep looking up
[Music]
you